today's video is sponsored by Hero Wars
which means if you guys head down to the
link in the description you can get a
massive reward on this guy's link you've
got a link down there my link your link
click your link it's an action RPG
you've got over 130 missions all of them
held together with one of the best
stories I've seen on mobile games I know
what you're thinking oh you've seen some
good stories on mobile games this is the
best of them levels levels for this
there is levels to this yeah especially
with Heroes and Wars
but the point is there's a community of
over 100 million people on this game
there's 100 million people who are on
this game that my friends is incredible
the more you go through the more skills
you learn and the better Heroes you will
unlock you start with someone like me
work up to someone like him the game
right now has over 50 completely
different Heroes all with unique skills
love a good unique skill on my hero and
you've got everything from cyborgs
aliens vampires and loads more choices
they're individuals they're Helen just
cloned the same guy
each person bringing a different set of
skills to the table what would you go
out of that would you go cyborg vampire
or alien probably vampire yeah I've
always felt like that suited me because
um sort of cold-blooded and nocturnal
now if you use his Link in the
description below and download the game
you'll get a super chest just like that
that's a super chest yeah although this
is a very different kind of what's that
what's that like no places you'll get a
super chest with five top heroes and one
of them is a secret
we don't talk about that yeah and you'll
also get 600 emeralds and 30 000 gold
just scan the QR code or download the
game from the link below the video by
downloading that game you will be
supporting this channel the content that
we make and obviously helping yourself
out because you'll be downloading Hero
Wars that means a correct game hero
award put the put the graphic up
[Music]
thank you
we should do some problems today
actually because we usually get people
sending them yeah problems
um do you know people have real problems
people are in court uh Amber Heard and
Johnny Depp smooth transition good one
no seriously this this whole thing is
pretty it feels open and shut and I
can't quite understand why they're going
through this whole rigmarole well
they're going through the rigmarole
because we live in a society
that means you can have
30 plus years of success a good
reputation all right you do some drugs
you act like a rock star but you know
let's barely make a mega pint of one I
best believe Johnny Depp has been
killing the game for multiple decades
and all of that can be undone
with a sentence from someone an
accusation no trial needed no proof
needed trial by just the minute you get
accused of anything it doesn't matter
everything you've done before that
you're guilty doesn't matter you gotta
admit she was very compelling in the way
that she made the accusations and the
accusations were so
um there were multiple accusations she's
a very she was very good at crafting
this public image of her being the
victim him being the aggressor well
there's been a precedent set there by
multiple women who've done this before
at a very successful men and let's be
honest you know there's there's a track
record of that because there's a massive
pot of gold at the end of it you know
what I mean right you either win money
or you become the victim in which case
you're sort of
because every relationship is messy like
very rarely do people just go through
life just sort of going oh I love you
and I just can't wait for us to spend
the rest of our lives together like
people will have fights and there's
probably some form of either abusive or
some form of uh toxic behavior in any
relationship from any age I'd imagine
because very rarely do people always
deal with things 100 well all the time
so if you've got someone who's gonna
accuse people and not deal with
something internally and go hey we're in
a relationship here we need to deal with
this like I think you have this trait
that we need to address if I'm going to
be in a relationship with you some
people will go I'm going to go public
with this and I'm going to try and ruin
you with it well on a law level we see
idiots doing that on Facebook in their
everyday lives you know what I mean you
see those women
it's because he's got a chip a lot of
dick well yeah you see that um and look
it's men and women to be fair who do
that [__] but and what I what I want to
make sure we see if we're going to
tackle this is they're saying about men
versus women women versus men like this
is a really weird situation that is not
comparable to any of our Lives I think a
lot of people like that would touch
their own identity to one of these two
there'll be men out there who've been
hurt by a woman who are rooting for
Johnny and there'll be women out there
who've been in abusive relationship who
maybe are rooting for uh whatever our
name is Amber that's what you have to
say but but bear in mind we're not on
anyone's side here it's either Johnny or
whatever the [__] her name is no but
it's it's the point is I mean we'll get
on to her but the point is is we can't
um pick sides based on what we've been
through that we need to look at this uh
objectively speaking or try to be as
objective yeah because I think I've seen
a lot of people posting
on team men or team women and I think
that's the total wrong way to look at it
like these are celebrities they're not
normal people and I'd say celebrities I
mean he's a celebrity she obviously he's
a successful actress who just wants to
be able to she got about the cross I
mean let's be real like she's a classic
social climber and I'm gonna say it how
it is with her we know her for who's
been inside her not for what she's been
in right you know which is a movie which
is like Elon Musk and Johnny Depp are
like she's got a very specific kind of
man you know and her type is certainly
not based on looks because Johnny Depp
and Elon Musk do not have the looks in
common let's be real no and the D in Her
IMDb stands for dick fully
um so that's that's the type of woman
she is and I know that you know there'll
be people out there who are criticizing
uh already because it's like oh you know
women women this is not about women this
is about a woman this she does not
represent all women but broadly speaking
I do think believe leave victims usually
they are telling the truth but when it
comes to a situation where the man in
this case and in often in Celebrity
cases
um is far wealthier far more successful
than the woman and it you know there's a
massive opportunity there for a woman
again from that which is exactly why
Chris Brown Cristiano Ronaldo Conor
McGregor and many many many other men
out there have had these organizations
at the very top level uh because as a
woman what's the worst that can happen
you you know you don't get the money all
right but you don't get most of the time
you don't get punished for these
um fake accusations or lies or whatever
if they are proven to be lies so
therefore all right you didn't you
didn't win the money but you go home at
the end of it only when people get
punished for the [__] that they do
they're trying to do like with an even
punishment that the guy would have
gotten if these lies were he was
convicted of the lies yeah but I get
that there's kind of the only issue with
that is that if then say the person who
is actually a victim and has accused
someone can't prove it but wants to go
to court with it and those kind of
things and that's why it's so Mass
issues so you can't punish the accuser
essentially but I guess there is a like
a wider punch but if you are phoned if
you're found to be fabricating I think
then that's a whole other level and
that's what we're at right now because
Johnny Depp that's what he's sort of
trying to proven doing a great job at it
is the amount of Lies this woman has
been caught in in court is enough for me
to go not nowhere near as much of this
as true as what she claimed you know do
you think at any point like there was a
point where there was no road back for
her she made the accusations she'd sort
of she probably made some
but she thinks she's quite a smart
person first of all she's clearly got
some more sorcerer paths too right okay
and and we can class it we're classing
her as a sociopath absolutely okay
um there's no loving her at all she is
pure cold reptilian villain right even
though there are times where obviously
she she professes to love or says I
loved or Johnny was the love of my life
what do you feel like these are just
words to You Johnny Depp is a mess of a
man this is not me sitting there going
he's perfect and she's about that do you
think he's a okay I I think as a as a
professional actor he is greatness but
is as a in his personal life he clearly
has some demons and unfortunately
when you have those you are susceptible
to be manipulated by by someone who you
think is the look after you or whatever
um so I personally feel like she's
seeing that knew she was hot as [__] uh
and she's in cheers actually attractive
because when I look at her I sort of go
mid-level secretary no but uh
like I don't mean that in a sexist way
either like you know I get well you
could be a middle level
mid-level Terror like I'll give her any
of these I get you she's got the
secretary look about her in the suit
especially she does the hair up and you
know she's not Ally McBeal because Ally
McBeal had like a little whoa but she's
very you know you've gone all over with
this Ali McBeal and anyway was a TV show
in the late 90s early 2000s about a
semi-successful lawyer I think you
should parallel she was a hot lawyer
basically but yeah she wasn't a
paralegal I get I mean you've really got
into the ghosts I'm sorry you had a
thing for her huh no it's just more that
I remember it being I was too young to
watch it and but at the time I remember
watching the adverts on Channel 4 and
going
something cool about that yeah okay so
here's how I said a a guy who had a
really unhealthy addiction a few of them
by the sound yeah drugs yeah the the guy
the mega pints are great that was one of
my favorite clips of the whole thing is
when he goes mega this is the problem is
this trial has been so [__] goddamn
entertaining it's helped by the way it's
helped him that it's been televised and
it's been oh there's no road back for
her now because there's there's ways why
was it televised I don't understand it
there's some sort of legal thing I think
where I think they can almost choose
where they want it televised well look
you you were going down the road there
saying look did she just take this too
far and 100 she doubled down essentially
absolutely okay
now we're at the point where you've got
to prove it and unfortunately for her
so many of her facts are completely
wrong and there's so many lies she's
being I mean we're recording this today
just yesterday we had a tech guy are we
recording this today like no but sorry
like the day the day after the day after
a tech guy has just got up on the stand
and basically went yeah you know these
the only pictures of any any injuries
she sustained the only proof that she
has
um the the photo edits were done to the
pictures so the bruise on her arm the
only thing she's got pretty much she
dialed up the contrast no but what he
said was you can tell by the size of the
files that they've been or then this is
not the original photograph that they
have been doctored now that alone you're
like on top of all of the date mistakes
all of everything else that she's she's
been caught up in it's like my God we're
literally a major mistake though by the
way if you are going to fake the files
definitely make sure you export them at
the right level well what whatever so
amateur oh my God what were you thinking
it should be called amateur herd yeah
but um
here's the thing is um you know on top
of her saying she donated seven million
a charity which turned out to be a bold
face lie and then it turned out Elon
Musk yeah and Johnny Depp both donated
and you're just like but the point is is
I suppose when you're in a couple you go
yeah I did that
it's it's unreal man I'll get home and
flu goes I had a good podcast today and
I went yeah I think we did I mean we're
just a team we're just a team I mean
essentially we are but I never claimed
to have looked after our son all day and
she never claims to have gone hey that
was some good past podcasting we did
he's a [__] liar right and this is
the thing is Johnny though is not
perfect and I'm not saying he's the the
good guy can we unpack that for a second
go for it so I I do think you're right
but what I know about abusive
relationships especially having spoken
to uh like my my mum about it like she's
a counselor she's but we spoke a lot
about kind of just Dynamics within
relationships and I often I realize if
you go to counseling very often you're
not in a happy relationship very few
people are in a happy relationship go we
should get counseling just for the sake
of it like
um and I was talking to her about how
you unpack and how abusive relationships
work and one of them was one question I
have for it was like what happens
because abuse can be a very long term
thing right like over two years there
can be a long pattern of abuse and it
can often start very early on especially
if someone's a sociopath and has got a
history of abuse it can literally start
with the rears of an eyebrow when you
say something and it that's where the
manipulation begins where it's just like
what you think that do you right and
like and that's all you know you're
being criticized right you're being
mentally bullied into a place where you
can't then speak your mind right and
that's the start and what is unusual and
it's kind kind of interesting about the
whole that I was always struck by be
careful The Company You Keep sort of
comment because
the abused can also then get sucked into
the abusive cycle themselves and that's
what I was saying's mom was like how do
you distinguish who's the person that's
doing the abusing if it if you know
shouting goes both ways it's very rare
that in an argument one person will just
shout at another and the other person
will just sit there sort of timid so
you've got to kind of unpack and unpick
very
Tangled relationships and that's what I
think is interesting about this trial is
people want it to be one or the other
she's clearly an abusive character you
can tell and I have no problem saying
that like I I passed judgment on her
I think with him it is more like
he's been sucked into a pattern of
behavior then he's then mirrored
replicated
abusive relationship people try to find
ways to deal with the other person and
very often the only way to deal with an
abusive person
is to almost Fight Fire with Fire if
that makes sense or that's the way it
would feel and it does feel like in the
moment
um but
look we're the one thing that I do think
that this is exposed a little bit is
how men can be abused by women because
on
even powerful man uh yeah and I think
although I've said it's not a woman and
a female versus male thing
in this in this sense
um you I think men often feel like
we're living in a new generation where
women are finding their voices finally
and that is giving them a level of power
to
um speak up for themselves when they
have been a victim of abuse and
specifically uh with men it tends to be
physical for whatever reason genetically
what whatever however we're built it
seems that that's often the case but
there is a
like a silent form of abuse in terms of
with left without marks but and I think
we're we've seen it in this relationship
where how a man can be ruined by a woman
without I mean to be fair ironically
there's far more evidence including an
admission
that says she hit him she is openly
admitted she is him and there's a lot
more evidence to say she was physical
towards him much more if at all than he
was towards her right
um
so
I think that's the that's the difficult
thing is there is a lot of these
relationships that I've seen
where a woman is just downright nasty to
a man and is sort of
mentally ruining him
but because and just like Amber Heard
herself said tell them tell them you're
a man tell them you're a victim because
and that is how men feel like out there
right now and it's something that isn't
really being addressed because
um there are more important things I
guess in in in the world going on in
Scales yeah because like you know I
remember when that that cop killed that
girl last year and how women were
speaking out about how they felt and I
and I totally get that in in the in the
pecking order it's far more important
address
women's safety physical safety but at
the same time
we should be trying to tackle all of
these problems and I think that there
are
um men who just don't feel like they can
speak out until it's too late almost and
and often you will and we've we've seen
documentaries where you know I love you
now Die For example where a woman
basically got a man to kill himself yeah
and and you can remember and that's a
very extreme example but the point is is
if someone isn't in a mentally Strong
place and you are coming from a position
of strength or heartlessness in which
case you feel nothing which I think is
the way Amber Heard operates a lot of
the time she's definitely sociopathic in
my opinion you can ruin someone into a
position where they just wither away and
wither away and wither away unless they
find the strength from somewhere and I
think that that's what we're witnessing
in Johnny Depp right now is a man who
she tried to take everything from him
and it left him with almost a choice of
I either allow myself to wither away and
die which has happened to many powerful
people when they've lost that they feel
like they've lost all credibility or I
fight it and I have my day in court with
that and I think that that's what this
is more about rather than him winning
the 50 million lawsuit it's about him
having this out in public and getting
people to see the truth and then make
their own mind up about it after seeing
them both talk and I think a lot of
people have come to a similar conclusion
where we are right but also that he um
how can I put it like the guys the guide
lost everything like you say and it kind
of freed him up to do that because what
other alternative did she she [__] up
because she took too much it's that
level of arrogance I think which that
that will also be often a trait in
someone who's quite abusive they
obviously think they they they're
licensed to to give this abuse because
in their minds they're better than these
other people that they are abusing and
they have this sort of it's not it's not
a God complex but they definitely think
they're better than the other people
around them so they can treat someone
else in a relationship like that but
that leads to very obvious mistakes
absolutely yeah because you you when you
go for the jugular
it leads you it's like in a boxing fight
you know when you're going for the kill
you leave yourself wide open sometimes
and uh I think that that's what she's
done and
um she's she's ruined herself you know
whatever happens I think even even so
like Hollywood doesn't necessarily work
in the way where they go oh Johnny Depp
and you were both in a court case oh and
you came out in some way Victorious if
she does okay you'll get the movies it's
like she's so she's found right she
she made the mistake I think I knew what
they
when you make a union with another
person and you become some sort of power
couple in her head
even though to the rest of the world
he's had 30 years of success and she's
just come along and jumped on the gravy
train and he's literally helped get her
movies and help build her star up
because that's how a partnership works
she didn't say it the real way it was
because
as as what I've classed to be a
sociopath she has this like
heartlessness and thinks of herself on a
higher level than what she's got other
plans she's clearly underestimated him
uh especially with his drug addiction
and the mess that he was in and um
what she thought is we're going to have
a PR wall yeah I'm gonna go on the
offensive and I'm going to leave nothing
behind and paint myself out as the
victim and everyone will love me and
that's
claiming
victim
it's something that's becoming
a really unhealthy pattern in society
where right men and women people run
towards that title and they and instead
of owning up and going look that was a
toxic [__] relationship we're both
better off out of it you know I didn't
behave well he didn't behave well but
you know what I wish him well all the
best yada yada let's move on she she
struck first right ask questions later
and um and and she she wanted to make
sure that she came off as the good guy
in this so that she would be okay and
because of that
she [__] up in my opinion yeah I
especially think it's become quite a
weird label victimhood in society
because that victim is a perfectly valid
position for a lot of people in the
relationships that they've been in or in
the the place they found themselves and
it seems to be a position a lot of
people want to avoid right now but it is
a perfectly valid position to be in but
the issue is it's become quite a toxic
word and it's got a lot of connotations
now when someone is a victim that the
victim probably doesn't want and I don't
think it helps
in general uh Society you've got people
ending relationships but waiting for the
moment where the other person does
something wrong so they can feel so that
yeah so they can go right at over now
right instead of just coming out with it
you know and it's quite meta in that
sense like it's like these people are
that's that in itself is a lack of
strength for you rather than overall in
the relationship it shows a lack of
strength in a relationship when you're
basically going I'll wait for them to
mess up and then then I'll be able to
feel all right because what you're
basically saying is I can forget all the
bad that I did because they did the bad
thing last absolutely and but that is
how that's that's quite an immature
place
online right now I've never been more
fed up with the way people are like
really I'm I'm I'm I'm really I just see
through all the [__] and I'm
absolutely sick to death of it like the
way people get swept up in this and
believing everything immediately without
quite like
and that's that's where the issue is
here with
um believe all victims and it's like
generally speaking I get the thought
process behind that sure but the reality
is
in these circumstances when people have
got so much to gain you're a comma
Johnny Depp is a commodity he is some he
has something absolutely and you can't
treat that the same way as you would
treat Joe blogs who paints [__]
houses and I get that and and that's
kind of that's the that's the other
aspect of you can't map on your own
situation to Johnny Depp and Amber Heard
because those people are operating at
just a completely different level of
cash the guy that really would fly out
the [__] Islands get [__] off his
face drink and smoke as much as he
wanted and he knew I'd have a good
[__] time do you think um because
it's weird someone messaged me the other
day on Instagram and went I've been
canceled and I was like
tough tough break bro like and then he
went no no in like my Village I've been
canceled and I was like okay and I was
like this is what I'm talking about no
but but and I get it but there's a there
is an issue there that like his whole
world is his village
and he was like everyone hates me what
do I do now and he was like it's a bit
like the Johnny Depp Amber Heard thing
in a way and I was like it really isn't
but I get that like that your whole
world is this little village area
I feel like the canceling it's not
cancer culture but the canceling of
people is becoming it's becoming a real
problem because of the dynamic it causes
where you're essentially telling telling
people your life as you know it is over
and you're giving them so little hope
this is why Caroline flock killed
herself because right because she felt
like that was the case that her
reputation was ruined and she had been
shamed beyond belief right and she
unfortunately could not find the
strength to fight it I hope and maybe
that was because she had done some of
the things that people were accusing of
but the bottom line is is like
even if you have made mistakes
we as a society have to be a bit more
forgiven of people if there's logic or
if there's acceptance and apologies and
and true signs that you are sad about
what you've done and want to change or
what but that isn't unfortunately
um so here's how it works you get the
person who makes the mistake you get the
mob who reacts to it you get the guy in
the mob who sees an opportunity to
further their own career whether that be
man or woman to buy
um making content around that all being
the victim around that or using this
situation to further their own uh light
yeah and that's what they do and because
there's such a reward scheme there we're
always going to have white Knights as I
like to call them who put themselves out
there to be the Savior and the one to
say well this is wrong and I'm right and
I'm I'm the great person who's going to
tell you why and and all of that and uh
and unfortunately
um this is how it works you know what I
mean and I'm not even saying
um I Heard should be necessarily
canceled but unfortunately for her she's
left herself with no place to turn
because she's revealed just how rotten
she is that is part of the problem is I
don't feel I I she's not she's not
apologizing she's not accepting reality
and that's that's the key here that's
where acceptance forgiveness comes in
when you're willing to be wrong and
willing to accept what you've done wrong
but from everything I'm saying her
throwing bottles at Johnny here throwing
punches at Johnny multiple injuries that
Johnny had sustained within that time
and yet
with her the complete lack of evidence
and the evidence she does have it turns
out that it was photoshopped uh you know
and the the the amount of time she said
he did this to me and then the very next
day she's photographed looking
absolutely fine and couldn't possibly
have sustained the injuries that she's
claiming right there's so much that just
doesn't add up so you know I'm all
willing to be forgiving but this is
ridiculous now you've taken it to a
point where you've tried to destroy this
man and you're lying clearly on so many
different things how much can can I ask
you about this because I always find
this really interesting very often the
people who are abusive in relationships
have been through some form of trauma
there's something bad there that's
happened and that will program their
mind in a specific way to then either
replicate that or that's the only kind
of system that they understand it
programs them in a certain way why are
we blaming someone for being something
that we should almost expect them to be
if that makes sense
and how do you deal with that does that
does that question make sense like if
you program a computer to do something
and then it does it yeah you don't blame
the computer at a certain point we've
got to judge people uh by adult
standards and I get that but even in a
we found consistently even in adults
adults make these mistakes on a daily
basis and for some weird reason we treat
these qualities as intrinsic to this
person I'm not saying Amber Hood's not
guilty right but I don't like the term
guilty not guilty in these kind of cases
because I feel like bad things happen to
these people in their life very often
that cause them to become guilty
do you get what I'm saying with this I
think like it's a defamation trial yeah
and she is 100 lied about Johnny Depp to
ruin his image that is exactly I mean
case closed I don't know if he'll win
but I'm not questioning that that's not
what I'm I'm not saying like I I think I
don't care if he wins or not you know I
think he's in the right but the problem
is I feel like too much to society is
based around you are this person that
person is intrinsic to you and you'll
never get over that so you know you will
cast your size
I mean I'm trying to answer the question
as best I can yeah you can't you can't
get through it we've seen that many
times where people have come back
stronger and being canceled now is is
not necessarily what people make it out
to be I think we've seen so many people
go through the flames and all of a
sudden it's like oh it's not actually
that bad here and that's why you can
sort of laugh at it if you're strong
enough in that moment this is [__]
but you have to be able to take control
of the situation Own It own up to
anything that you are guilty of and then
but the problem is is when you do double
down like Amber heard's doing to such a
ridiculous degree she gave herself no
other option and there was a moment
where someone recently asked Johnny in
the uh on the stand you know how do you
feel about all of this I don't know if
you've seen the answer but it was like
he took a minute and I mean he tends to
do that with every [__] answer he
gives yeah but um makes the trial a lot
longer um
um well uh I guess uh yeah but he's very
considerate but he he was like his first
words were like how how has it been for
you to be listening to everything she's
accusing you of and his first word was
insane yeah like which I thought was was
such a great word I was like because he
was like you know like and then he just
went on a like a tirade of answers but
it wasn't aggressive it was just like he
was like Preposterous yeah ridiculous
like none of which I'm guilty of nothing
not a thing you know what I mean like
and um he was like I've never sexually
assaulted her in any way ever or anyone
else and like it was just such a strong
answer and then you know by comparison
you've got her there going well I hit
him because of she's really not good
like you know if you're her team the
legal team and she goes it's all right
guys I've got this you go no we need to
you need to sit down and we need to go
over this because your demeanor on the
stand is terrible you look guilty you
come across awfully like you are you
don't come across as a nice person no
it's quite amazing that she was an
actress because I've never seen anybody
in my like I've watched serial killers
say that they didn't kill people but
there's all the evidence that they did
and I went you're making me questions
yeah yeah do you know what I mean like
she's she's no Ted Bundy no it's not
that out there yeah and I think that
might have been what she thought would
happen
she'll have a career to go but this is
the thing she won't she
did career to go back to there
iterus who
probably that but she's probably got
some she's probably a nice person or
sociopaths tend to present as nice
people like they tend to be very
alluring people they tend to lay traps
for people
right about three months after that you
basically go oh [__] get away at that
point you're having sex you've had lots
of jobs what you like you've publicly
presented you to other people maybe
you're speaking a little bit much from
personally sorry like I said this isn't
about us right and not about men or
women like but the point is by then
they've kind of got their claws in
they're sort of in your life a little
bit they've met a couple of friends and
it becomes a little bit like difficult
to break up with this person and then of
course like you know you go okay well
another six months one of my mates used
to say this like um I guess it's a bit
like this in a way it's like you make
such a great first impression and blow
them away with kindness early on that
and what he meant was he could then rest
on his Laurels afterwards not make as
much effort sure you know what I mean I
mean
yeah insanely great Whirlwind and then
it it deteriorates and a similar insane
fashion like um Tinder swindler kind of
thing like blow them away with something
and feel so valued so amazing the more I
look at that the crazier it seems like
that it's the whole thing but she I'd go
about her acting skills like um awful
the the you don't deserve another role
Miami like look it's we're not firing
you because of your guilty we're firing
you because you just couldn't even be
believable on the stand right this is
your you should be acting for your life
right now and yeah yeah but um it's it's
the way like it's like so tell us about
that night and she goes well I was
wearing a a beautiful red dress and the
way she like turns to the jury and and
performs to them whereas Johnny's just
very much like looks directly ahead
answers the cry and and occasionally you
know he will make
um I think the fact that he doesn't come
across as over emotional and he helps he
he plays it like
with her she turns the Waterworks on so
frequently and you can see it's just on
cue and yet
and
nobody's got a nice cry face but and I
know that this is totally irrelevant but
I don't I really hate her cry face like
it's really annoying yeah like you
really because you could just look and
you think you fake [__] lying cow I'm
gonna be honest with you as well I don't
get like the whole attraction thing I
don't think she's particularly
attractive like I don't think she's like
holy sh you know when you see Angelina
Jolie at any point in her life you go
holy [__] especially the Bone Collector
ironically um and and yeah she could
have collected your bone tell me about
it anyway the the point is
I don't look at her and go wow this is
incredible but I also don't look at her
and go you've been in some good films
this is a profile we're building here no
it's not quite a Rum Diary drive angry
which is probably something because of
him apparently as well you know really
oh she was in Justice League I think
look I think she's a pretty girl in all
of that right but
um yeah not not worth that kind of aggro
you know what I mean [__] that she
really if you throw this is the problem
noise
and and this is a a magic mic a tip or
trick uh for anyone out there who does
feel like they're in an abusive
relationship whether that be mental or
physical tell them no [__] actor once
you start seeing those signs you got to
get out quick because the longer you
stay the harder it gets the first time
she threw a [__] wine bottle at you
bro that's the time to get the [__] out
any woman throws a bottle at your
[__] head you need to get the [__]
out of there yeah because it's a vice
versa if it was a man throwing it at a
woman whatever raise your hands whatever
you know what I mean another big [__] up
is like
Every Woman who'd been with him for long
periods of time was like yeah he's like
the nicest guy would never ever do
anything like that and then she
mentioned Kate Moss or something she
mentioned it basically said he pushed
Kate Moss down the stairs is like he's
got a history of this Kate Moss
immediately gets on the stand and he's
never hit me ever in any time in any way
wow and then she goes the London look
and then just walks up she's got a real
funny voice Kate Moss I never know I
never got why they used it in the ads it
was always like get the London look yeah
it's very much like that yeah she sounds
like Amy Winehouse like I didn't expect
that to have that kind of
[Music]
yeah is she um she was never attractive
okay Moss you're really on a a rant
against women today I don't know if this
is a good idea what do you mean you're
just saying that they're not that that
hot I never got it I just thought she
was just I thought she was famous
because she was skinny yeah I I she had
I think models aren't necessarily
supposed to be beautiful in a
traditional way of the while they're
like you could see a girl walking down
the street who looks almost like very
attractive but almost too attractive so
that you wouldn't pay attention to the
clothes like I guess that's the point is
you kind of got to be can I just say I'm
not paying attention to you but you've
kind of got to be pretty but neutrally
pretty where it's not sure or overtly
yeah you've got like that great Gap in
your teeth and I think a lot of women
have this sort of like blend between
male and female almost their looks which
is why visually sort of has that very
feminine men often our selectedly models
for that same reason they got the high
cheekbones and all of that right because
they wouldn't want me modeling because
obviously I'm too nice possible do you
know I have noticed though is you know
if you're on Tick Tock and stuff like
that you um
you can see a lot of people who are sort
of bizarrely team that you know they
team up they do like the team Amber team
Johnny or team Man team women sort of
thing
how how does that work why would you
choose team Amber in this
what's the what's the thought process
behind clearly I think I think
I think there's a rational people all
over the world like I'm as much as we've
been team Johnny I I don't think Johnny
Depp is necessarily
the guy you'd want dating your sister
here you know what I'm saying yeah
absolutely I'm not saying he's a perfect
he's a drug addict and an alcoholic and
she's a sociopath and together she
drained him of a lot of his power and
and basically left him with a ruined
reputation when the relationship
spiraled out of control because she is a
hot head you can see that a male off the
way she struggles to contain that anger
you say that in I I don't want to sound
like I'm some sort of psychoanalyst but
it's very easy to say the rage within
like you can say it on her face half the
time when she's glaring at him in the
way she does yeah that is really strange
isn't it because it's almost like it's
almost like so originally her goal was
to ruin him right take him to court win
the court case she thought if I present
all of this I'll win it
she then adjusted her goal from being
that to just being whatever I get out of
this that is a win which is making him
sad you know just taking out any
aggression on him but seems to be the
adjustment here we've seen we've all
seen relationships before and this is
where it is comparable I think where
if I can't have him I will destroy him
if he's not with me I will leave nothing
left and I've had someone sort of have
that similar attitude towards me before
and I think
you know unfortunately on the level
where Johnny is he's got so much to lose
there's so much to take that whatever
happens
he'll never be the same person he would
have been had he not have met him well
no I I don't know if you said that he
did all right well that is you know this
is there's men out there who are women
as well obviously who work their [__]
life to get to a certain point and then
when you get there you realize it ain't
that great because you're literally then
a meal ticket a a a a Target
and that is why again
Chris Brown Cristiano Ronaldo Neymar
[__] Conor McGregor every successful
man in the entertainment industry has an
accusation under their name and and that
is not and I'm I'm sure one of them is
probably guilty of something I'm not
denying that but the point is is the
likelihood of every single one of these
guys being guilty of sexual assault when
women are throwing themselves at these
men on a daily [__] hourly second by
second basis
it's [__] you know it to a degree
like there's got to be a lot of it that
is lies and unfortunately enjoying that
unfortunately
um
it's it's the real price that these men
pay
where it's like well
if someone says one thing that's it and
you're immediately stuck with that
little tug forever and I think that with
Johnny there's a lesson to be learned
for a lot of successful people which is
if someone does make this accusation
against you
I get why you wouldn't fight it publicly
because sometimes it is potentially
easier if there is no truth to just
dismiss it move on with your life
but I think there's a lot to be gained
actually by going on the offensive now
and I think Johnny will have shown a lot
of men out there you know what [__] this
I'm gonna fight this and I'm gonna come
after you and I'm gonna come after you
and the way you've come after me and I'm
gonna make you go to court and I'm going
to show and with Johnny there was
there's so much evidence on his side and
I get that's why you're saying why would
anyone side with Amber but I think um I
can only imagine that maybe there's
women out there who have been through
what amber claimed to have been through
and they identified with that they're
connected with that not her but with
what she'd said and they feel like a win
for her as a win for them because they
might not have had the money to take the
guy to court or they might not have had
their day and with Justice and then they
had their living through her somewhat
vicariously and it doesn't make sense
but I don't blame them
um because well they're dealing with a
sociopath as well a sociopath doesn't
just impact the person they're with they
impact all those other they want to line
everyone up against these people so
essentially they're playing into what
she wants a sociopath has yeah she is
control she's the conductor here and in
the same way Ted Bundy had all of those
little girls in court cheering for him
loving him because they thought
something that was completely wrong
I I think that is what these people are
wrapped up in and unfortunately you're
always going to get that and again I'm
not saying Johnny Depp's a good guy you
wouldn't want him dating the assistant
the guy's a bit of a mess you know
personally he's [__] gorgeous the
kids would be beautiful but what you
don't I know obviously he's rich but
those things aren't the kind of things
that holistically you want your sister
to have you obviously wanted to have a
good life but you also wanted to be
happy and fulfilled and the likelihood
of that with an addict is low the curse
of success stories your options become
far too plentiful so like sure you know
we how many successful men really hold
down a relationship that is good in
every way shape or form like I know we
look at Instagram or whatever we see the
rock living the perfect life but
nobody's that perfect and if you look at
the Rocks misses she's not what you
would have expected potentially she's
quite a normal person and maybe that's
part of it for him that keeps him in
into and because if you you look at a
lot of men out there take who's that
comedian who had the documentary about
him
um little short guy oh Kevin Hart yeah
Kevin Hart famously had issues in his
relationship and many of these men have
like Will Smith's relationship is a
shambles like how many successful men
and a Will Smith's son odd case but how
many
is the odd case I mean yeah but the
point is is when you and and this isn't
me feeling sorry for them it's just the
facts of the matter when you've got
[__] thrown at you on a daily basis
you know it's easy for people to judge
and go oh well he shouldn't be he should
have kept it in his pants yeah
if Temptation was thrown at you whether
that be drugs alcohol money women cars
whatever how do you [__] react
because a lot of people in those
situations would just turn into a pig
who would collapse the first moment that
they are revealed is that or that they
are shown their own actions sort of
thing and that's why at a certain level
success becomes
less rewarding and more painful probably
there's there's probably a happy balance
that you can get to Pandora's boxes sort
of open by that point now yeah it's gone
you're [__] I'll read a message I had
like a day ago right right because I get
these every [__] day to be honest
with you this is your BT internet
um
we'll be installing your router on the
15th disgusting rat I hope you get
cancer and die a miserable death
I think they were looking for me
um that was at 7 37 a.m a.m good way to
start the day so have my coffee and
hope you get cancer and die so that
that's sort of that's a normal beginning
to the day for me that is very normal
have you know what I mean and as much as
I'm desensitized to it and I understand
that these people are mental clearly is
it it's obviously not a nice thing to
have to do but that's the point though
but that's that's normality for me that
is every day you know what I mean and
they're unfortunately when you have a
huge amount of people who watch you
there will be a percentage of absolute
[__] weird [__] who and and this is
the thing I just want to do content
right I just want to go about my day
leave me that like you know make some
nice comments on the video great you
know support what we do but like it's
the fanatical weird lunatics out there
who extremely who live for the downfall
of others and they and that is a a small
but very important uh population on
social media and these are the ones who
during a Johnny Depp Amber Hood they get
their rocks off to it because they're so
excited by the idea of the downfall of a
successful person right and as much as I
think Amber Heard is a [__] lunatic
weird [__]
um
she's also a person and I don't
necessarily want like I want to lose
this case but I don't necessarily want
anything bad to happen to her right you
don't wish a cancer upon this I mean
yeah a slow painful death as he said
um you know you know but this is the
thing though is like do you think in his
mind he just goes this will be a funny
thing to then to watch this no I don't
realize that I don't know I think
there's there's I don't know I think
there's a lot going on there but um I
mean Daddy okay uh yeah and and but this
is the thing is at that level this isn't
my level so at that level how weird is
it you know I bet you it is really
[__] and you you can't go for a piss
in a toilet without everyone wanting to
like Johnny Depp one of our biggest [__]
is yeah you know like every single part
of your life you are you know and I
remember
um real Ferdinand doing
um surprise uh that I mentioned his name
uh doing a TV show back in the day
called like punked or something where
you'd
so uh he played a practical job on David
Beckham but in the in the process we've
seen we it was a terrible show but you
know you know Rio's been trying for oh
yeah I remember this so David Beckham
runs and jumps into the back of a taxi
and the joke is that the taxi driver
will not give David Beckham what he
wants and he'll just keep driving him
and and and the the tax driver is really
good actually I remember God you mind if
I just stopped in yeah I've just got to
pick some Quavers up or whatever I'm
getting a bit package but he's obviously
there wine backs up but the point is
that David Beckham runs and jumps into
like this car as if the building behind
him is exploding yeah and he acts like a
weird guy like David Beckham is and
that's not because he started off as a
weird guy it's because this life is
weird you can see the distress on his
face yeah because he's sick of being
pestered by Paparazzi and not feeling
like he can trust anyone around him yeah
and that's what this [__] does to you
yeah and we've normalized this extreme
element of like hyper relationships in
society and suddenly people think they
can just go and talk to anyone in any
way they like you see that Anthony
Joshua clip
yeah AJ was getting some [__] off some
Muni students saying about duck and
Tyson Fury or something so he just was
like you know I'll crack your [__]
jaw
and uh you won't like it it's like no I
get that
um I I really rated it because
you know I can break down in Anthony
Joshua fight and say well I think of
strengths and weaknesses are and make
the odd Joe but I'm under No Illusion
the mind deserves respect big time and
if he's around you
but this is the thing is if you've never
been in a boxing gym before I guess like
these skinny little uni students had
yeah we haven't
um
you probably don't understand what he's
gone through in order to get to the
point he's at you know but he did duct
Tyson Fury well I think he wanted to
fight him but he ended up fighting the
USA who beat him you know um I do but AJ
is actually game to be fair it seems
that way yeah but you know he's the real
deal EJ I I credit him for that like
he's a fighting man do you ever think
though there is a bit of a strange thing
about going up and threatening skinny
little guys I think that that I think he
was doing them a favor in my opinion
there that was like
as a big guy even I've had a few little
moments where it's not about it's not
about you're doing them a favor you're
going you do know like you keep pushing
this it's going to be bad for you and
sometimes I think with today's
generation of lads they're
there's not enough of them who've had a
stiff bang in the face as Adam Mccalla
says which is bang on and uh they they
set their lip off you know what I mean
and that's why there's a lot of like
there's a lot of scared kids out there
using knives and [__] like that and
there's there's now more people trying
to get um people into boxing and and
Muay Thai or yeah because you learn that
you learn respect and discipline and
learn not to [__] with people who could
[__] you up there is definitely and
that's what I'm saying is this hyper
reality definitely plays with the
boundaries of what respect is like you
know if you watch our podcast you watch
Logan's podcast you watch a lot of
people's podcasts remember when Logan
nearly flipped on that kid
where you realize you're not on the
other side of a screen like you're not
reacting to a video also that you feel
that that person is so famous they've
got so much to lose that they're never
going to do anything absolutely yeah and
then that's that's where the mistake
lies as well and I see Joshua no you
know this Public Image thing I don't
[__] with it and I'm like
huh no like it's he's the worst person
to [__] with you know there's a really
aggressive Alpha melee do people
obviously also forget what happened
before for him like you know how
aggressive he was he wasn't yeah not not
always nice in this yeah like his the
reason he doesn't say very much
I'm sometimes not sure whether he trusts
himself to say the right thing sometimes
or like to be in the right headspace
exactly he's media trained I think he
dealt with it perfectly because if he
didn't want to be if he wanted to say
something he said it he didn't go in
there swinging for the fences some
Fighters would have done now again I
think they got lucky that it was AJ in
fact because AJ is a bit of a Savvy
businessman and is it of all the
meteoric Rises I've seen AJ has handled
it possibly one of the best like if you
compare that to Conor McGregor who was
punching an old man for giving him some
lip you know bit different you know AJ
with a group of young Lads ones yeah
I'll break your jaws and you won't like
it yeah you know shut the [__] up
imagine if one of them went no I'd like
it gone
but listen I like the payout but I kind
of got that for the rest of your life
you can go Anthony Joshua broke my yeah
this is the thing it wouldn't be worth
it that's the thing right like it really
would hurt and it wouldn't be worth it
but that's the stupidity in in some
young man today that fearlessness it's
like fear is a very good thing fear is
what keeps you safe is what stops you
from doing dumb [__] like challenging
Anthony Joshua to you know what I'm
saying yeah yeah like I might make jokes
about [__] certain Fighters or
whatever but you know I'm not uh stupid
enough to say certain things in their
[__] company also jokes have a time
and place and like you know very much I
think if someone arrives on a YouTube
video or whatever it is you're very much
expecting to have an evaluation yeah if
it's labeled like evaluation or fights
it's not like Anthony Joshua's turning
on and going this is going to be a
loving but there is there is a
difference and when the man's in your
vicinity you have to give them a
different kind of respect because it's
we're not here entertaining people right
now you're deal around me yeah and that
becomes different then it's like Jake
Paul
um who was given Tony bellew a bit of
jokey band and saying I don't know who
that guy is and Tony Bellevue said like
we bummed into each other and he shook
my hand said I do respect you you know
what I mean and it's that's what it's
about it's like as a two-faced but no
but as a man you get that like he's just
playing the game you know what I mean
and yeah as a YouTube guy playing the
game and I'm a bit of fun and making
your joke about a fighter but in person
it's like me come on of course I I wish
I was as someone who had that career I
wish I was a world champion I wish I'd
done what you've achieved well it's also
not only that like Jake Paul in that
situation has got I know it's weird
because the it very often you can boil
being an alpha male down two can this
person knock this other person out right
I mean that's literally what it's all
about dude deep down right and I feel
like I have a shot with some of these
guys
I I but like the point is with Jake Paul
in that situation is actually the alpha
because he walks in he's got the profile
he's doing big things in boxing right
now Bell you would probably want to be
involved in some of those things I think
Jake well in terms of in terms of
business do you mean in terms of
business not because of the fighting
yeah and so he couldn't he can tell Tony
uh it's just it's just me be doing the
game but if Tony did want to take
exception to it he could he could do
that and then and then he becomes the
alpha but Tony essentially knows no
Jake's got in a in a powerful young
position here and I need to respect that
in a sense yeah
um when you challenge another man like
I've had
uh you know I've I remember a story you
know when I've challenged a Blog before
it was a very rich man who thought he
sort of
thought he could talk down to me because
I was working for his company yeah and I
quickly let him know that that meant
nothing to me
and and we all walked away hopefully
fine and the dynamic changed immediately
you know what I mean
um and it's a bit like I always like the
scene in Batman where um someone's
talking down to Ben about I've given you
all this money I've done this and he
goes oh yeah and that somehow gives you
power over me I don't know I think he
twists his neck and kills him yeah he
does yeah and I always like that because
that that and that's the thing is like
unfortunately one of the worst things
about social media and the false
confidence this Young Generation has is
that it's not only Young Generation old
men that have messaged me like you need
to sort your head out mate you need your
chin spinning you're like do I please do
go on some people start just to like I
don't know they want to like I met
someone the other day who wanted to be a
house influencer
um
and I I sort of struggled with it
but they
they just kept posting things about
their house over and over and over and
over and over and over and over again
they only had like a thousand followers
and they were like no I'm an influencer
I was like no he's a normal person with
an Instagram account there's got to be
we've got to differentiate these things
like not everyone is maybe you're a
micro influencer but you're not a micro
influencer is just a person who has
Instagram
this whole thing is just [__] and I
hate it the Ricky Gervais influence
thing is quite interesting I want to get
I I think I just want out of life like
um of the of the uh the Internet it's
it's the internet yeah have you seen the
new Ricky Ray stand up because things
called Supernatural Supernatural I
haven't seen it okay is this where you
mix the trans jokes
Ricky pretty much goes to go out there
and say everything offensive like he
makes jokes about Chinese people you
make or you know makes jokes that sort
of allude to uh you know Chinese people
looking very similar or certain people
around the world looking very similar
um he said this is the thing is I think
he's he's approaching that really
perfect age that for him right you know
when you hit that midnight
and he's just like you know what I'm
gonna go out in a Blazer Glory because
I'm old enough to not give a [__] no
more I kind of think it show like it's
an interesting position that a lot of
comedians are taking up now where their
position is about
challenging I think they're fighting for
their lives essentially because cancel
culture has come
so aggressively at comedians because
what a media a comedian does is it says
ridiculous things to make people laugh
that aren't serious right but what
cancel culture is is often taking those
things out of context to destroy people
and often attack
very serious things yeah very often like
for instance with trans
um gender jokes I've like I watched this
thing I thought the transgender jokes
were obviously they were well thought
out but they were they were not I didn't
I they weren't like side splittingly
funny but I remember when Ricky was
early like you know animals and politics
like I loved that Ricky gervaisera he's
not that same Ricky Gervais these jokes
are were weirdly like felt construct I'm
not it's not criticism I'm just saying
how they were these weird jokes were
constructed almost two
make that point exactly like I can make
a joke and it can be offensive or it can
be whatever it is he sticks to the
formula exactly yeah he's worked I would
hope to do Ironclad jokes that you can't
really get him on right while making a
point at the same time and he keeps
going like irony afterwards and he'll be
it his what he signposts at the very top
of the thing is like I will sometimes be
ironic tonight or I will sometimes you
know jokes aren't just verbatim he said
that joke and that joke was literal
every every comedian is doing the same
thing now because they have to because
of the way people take things out of
context because the funniest thing to
talk about is often the most bizarre or
most dark thing and to exaggerate sure
an opinion that isn't serious so there
was one guy who um Jim Jefferies JJ okay
Jim Jeffries
um and he goes like
you know um
you know uh Bill Cosby
turns out he just loves to rape people
right you know yeah and he goes you know
how you feel about chocolate or movies
that's how he feels about right right
and then he's like I'll tell you what
though
if I was to be raped
I would love it to be of Bill Cosby
because he drugs your first wow okay you
know and so he but that he says
ridiculous things and that sort of [__]
right but the point is he goes at the
end he goes just to be clear rape is a
terrible thing and I you know and that's
that's how they construct these these
these jokes these days and it's it's
often all the same because they're all
under attack from the same people
they're all fed up so they're all having
to Ironclad these jokes and to make it
super obvious what they're playing with
but that's kind of that that almost
defeats the purpose of it because I feel
like comedy and making jokes and Def or
definitely where I see it from and this
is kind of probably what's got me in
trouble in the past is and you like you
you're there to play but you're being a
little bit you are playing with ideas
and when you're doing I know you don't
want to be obvious and that's the
problem because comedians are having to
make it super obviously we're comedians
by the way no but in the past we've met
we've made very subtle jokes that we
know our jokes but we but we think that
it's funny to not be obvious about it
and therefore it makes it more funnier
but it's funnier to me when the funniest
part is when there's someone that
doesn't get it exactly and that's why we
love the office because and not that
we're on the level of the office we're
well about that [__] the point is is
it's a joke it's called irony yeah the
point is is we love we love the office
because they're so straight faced and
that's what makes it funnier because you
don't know what's serious and um when
someone says something ridiculous with a
straight face it is hilarious but the
problem is now as comedians they're not
really able to do that you know I think
uh Tim Dillon is one of the few who kind
of pulls it off so Tim Dylan's got it
because Tim Dylan is in a sweet spot but
he doesn't [__] doesn't give a [__] but
he's also gay
um it gives him a level of protection is
that it gives him this thing where he
goes I'm a minority so essentially it's
like it super cancels out whenever
someone and that's the problem is the
fact that you need some sort of um you
know gay card or whatever kind of black
card or to protect or whatever you want
to talk to protect you yeah against
console culture shows how ridiculous
cancel culture is because everyone
should be trapped the same but they're
not we should be treating all comedians
under the under the pretense that this
person is here to say funny things that
aren't serious we should not even have
to mention that at the start of
everything
apart from Bad comedians I get it but
female comedians I well not there's so
much there's some good female comedians
I there was um
no uh we'll get one
and the no there was the one with the
hair oh actually do you know who I do
think is really [__] funny I don't
know where she's gone
um what the [__] was her name Nikki
Glaser was really [__] funny she had
her own podcast for a long time comedy
is dominated by men because men have big
Egos and we want to stand up on stage
and make people laugh and I do
understand that that's partly don't know
our narcissism but that is 100 but and
that's that's what we've liked to play
with in the past and by the way one
thing I'm also sick of yeah absolutely
I'm sick of people thinking that because
you because you have a podcaster because
you have a self-interest in yourself
that is a form of narcissism like and I
get it it probably is but being a
narcissist I guarantee everyone has a
sense of narcissism about their
personality there is no way of existing
without having any of these fallibility
elements to them people use victim
narcissist any of this sort of stuff a
shorthand for an insult now and we're
all
I don't feel like we've gotten the the
discourse the the conversation around
all this the sort of thing is changing
and no one's quite able to keep up with
how quickly it's changing when it comes
down to to jokes and that like really
reggae leave it
really uh
you know when he did the dead baby stuff
on the last one right that absolutely
killed me and the baby because the joke
is why his incompetent parenting yeah
and how he'd be so bad this is how
ridiculous it would be but broadly
speaking when the newspaper has reported
it it'd be Ricky Gervais dead baby well
you know well that's what and that's
what and that's what happens with the
Trans jokes the the in context yes trans
uh gender people are involved in the the
construction of the joke but it's never
the butt of the joke and there's a huge
difference and people like the muddy
those Waters constantly
um you know we've had a don't know us
many times and I'm so over it you know
what I mean because it's time to grow
the [__] up the internet need we need to
like we need to start looking at context
and for some reason that seems to have
gone out the window because the more
salacious uh easy target is what people
want to go and want to focus on when
they're being the White Knight who takes
down people instead of going actually is
this is this right because right and
wrong doesn't even seem to matter
anymore his stand up now is almost
exclusively basically all comedians are
having to go down that road that's what
I'm saying yeah I don't because I do
like it I don't do that I don't I don't
think it has funny anymore I think it's
kind of yeah like a lot of guys and
girls but more guys are more like
okay I I'm not quite sure how I can make
these jokes so I I have to sign both
things I have to do this I don't bother
that's how you stand out when Tim Dillon
goes off on a run
it there's nothing funnier for me right
because he ranted about you the other
day uh well it wasn't a rant but he was
sexting you from his side he was sexting
you and you were will you let's just
let's just like this no no no I want to
say how it is you were a willing
participant in
um unconceptual unconsensual homosexual
texting
I mean it was very consensual no no no
no no Brian from your side and this is
Tim Dillon um Tex wrecked you
kind of yeah I I I in a way no no don't
don't don't don't sugarcoat this just
because you want him on the podcast and
you then you want that juicy dick like
tell me Brian what happened I did say
when are you coming to London right did
you sell it c-u-m-i-n-g no right but he
said I'm a I'm gonna fly you out uh um
from Ireland right Ireland did you not
think at this point there is something
else that's going on something else is
going on so let me read me the text I'm
gonna read it uh I went you awake bro
you want I am now everything okay
uh by the way the fact that now we know
that he thought this was sexy changes
the entire context of oh yeah I am now
because I was listening to his podcast
and we've been talking about doing a
part together soon yeah and there was a
podcast where he basically had said like
because
another comedian in the space Brandon uh
Brendan um Rogers
Brandon Schaub not the the not the foot
not the Leicester manager yeah Brendan
Shaw but basically being
um accused of something whatever nothing
serious but just you know and I'm still
playing and Tim Tim Dillon basically
took took it on and was like look at the
end of the day he could rape me right
and I wouldn't say a thing he could he
could destroy my [__] and to the
point where there was blood and [__] all
over the bedroom and I would not say a
thing because I wanted to be about the
work right right and the whole thing
what the whole reason was about yeah
other people not being about the work
well yeah and basically I think that's
the point that he was in a really
roundabout way of getting up was like
you know I texted him just saying look
the fact that I've just listened to your
part about Brendan raping you and I'm
crying laughing and then he replied
you're allowed to rape me and I'm not
joking with that
face yeah it's got that one going Punk
squirrel IPA and I said I know you won't
say anything because you want it to be
about the work
and then I said gay comedian yeah and
then I said and I respect that yeah so
you're right okay and then he replies
you realize he's probably got his [__]
in his hand at this possibly he said LOL
I said do you know when you may be in
London
um he said I'm flying you here did you
forget oh I forgot who the [__] who is
this I'm texting the wrong person
and I was like it's bright
and he's like oh okay he goes I'm
texting some twink from Ireland thinking
it's you
but I'll get the date in the next two
weeks
I love that I also love that at the time
you you uh I played a lot you played
along but also the after you didn't
mention any of that bit but you did say
to me the next day I went I was just
texting Tim Dillon last night and you
didn't tell me about all the bit where
he thought that you were a twink smile
well I hadn't seen you yet so I was
going to tell you that yeah and then by
the time I seen you yeah
more people should be able to make those
kind of jokes but a lot of people can't
I think even I've refrained in the past
yeah when I watched him I feel inspired
to like Let It Go yeah yeah you worry
about upsetting people you don't want to
hurt people's feelings yeah and that's
not the goal but the point is is like
what we need to be able to do is trust
audiences trust the people at home to be
a grown ass [__] people who
understand we're not trying to hurt
people's feelings and I think
unfortunately
especially a year ago when you had that
[__] you know the jokes were taken
the wrong way and whatever it's
we're living in a world where that is
deliberately done sometimes where people
right where it's not about whether or
not you're joking it's about you said
this therefore you're done you know and
also the thing that pissed me off Moses
I'm going to tell you what you meant
that's what annoys me about this and
that's what annoys me about the Ricky
Gervais thing is when people go he made
trans jokes and here's what he means by
that and here's what that means yeah
yeah exactly and you know when you've
got grown people who are capable of
talking for themselves uh it's
frustrating and I think that's why
comedy comedy is in a really [__] place
at the moment like when you like and the
Chris Rock thing you know Chris Rock
making a very mild joke jokes that you
know he would 20 years ago we make way
worse jokes you know what I mean and I
think like it's one of the worst things
about this censorship and the modern the
modern day with social medias everyone's
[__] okay
is there is there an element of the
reason the jokes feel so salacious and
so funny is because we also know that
there is a risk socially so without the
risk the other way the jokes don't feel
quite as edgy like you need that in
order to have the edge you need to have
the risk and the risk here is that you
are risking upsetting someone and you
know that's part of it like that's part
of the whole dynamic here though Chris
Rock took the risk and he and credit
team took the consequences of it it's
just that
and this is this is the gym the Jim
Jefferies thing where it towards the end
he go he's because he swears his head
off he's an Aussie and when he was
talking about the The Bill Cosby thing
and going on about you know what Bill
Cosby was doing
he then goes at the end sorry about my
swearing yeah he goes do you know which
comedian ever saw Bill Cosby right and
he was a great guy wasn't he right and
that's the point is like
it's the it the people who are letting
all hung out the people who are not
afraid to say what the [__] on their
mind and do make more mistakes publicly
and do just let it go they're the
trustworthy ones it's the ones who come
smiling and are cut clean cut and always
and always pointing the finger and
always in the right they're usually the
worst people seen a good documentary the
other day uh our father
sure if you want to talk about coming
you heard about it where uh I know about
it I don't really need to watch it I get
I think I can imagine it and imagine all
that it is so please do describe it
basically where's it set Harkins it's
it's America okay it's America America
yeah it's set in America no but uh
basically this Giza was um a doctor and
he was a bloody good woman bloody good
doctor understanding member of the
community if you know what I mean when
it comes to helping people conceive
babies because he was artificially
inseminating women
with Little Swimmers with his own semen
and they were believing that their
husband's semen were being used turns
out the man had like 50 [__] kids or
whatever floating around who all
believed I thought they were more than
50. oh at least yeah I can't remember
the number because at that point I was
like what the [__] all these people
realizing they were related and so many
more who probably had no idea yeah right
or were in denial
yeah they were they were all and and all
close together because he was in a state
right and these guys what upsets me
about this is this guy wasn't like some
John Stamos [__] who's really
pretty boy nah this guy was ugly do you
know what I mean like an ugly guy and
this is another thing so like so the
women will come in often with their
fella the fellow would hand the spur
more though he'd be like right I'll pop
in in a second and actually need to go
and prepare and when he was preparing
she'd be laying there with her legs
apart yeah and he'd be in the other room
not going to one go he's an issue men
cannot be trusted gynecologist well this
is the thing though is is I'm watching
it and I'm like well surely the guy gets
in prison I mean he's ruined the lives
of so many people do you know what they
were like they went yeah but there's not
really a law against that that's the
problem I'm like [__] can we [__]
make one right because I feel like in
the modern day we should be able to go
this is a new kind of crime where a
doctor is producing hundreds of children
against the will of these women he's bit
he's on a level it's rape in some way
shape before what's the difference by
the way between uh you know
let's just break this down okay
essentially this guy has gone into
another room prepared his penis then
like within seconds of him coming in a
cup it's walked in the other room it's
the same as him basically walking back
into the room as he's about to come and
go and open those up
and like just shoving his dick in and
just that the the yeah so that it's
almost the only legality is like the the
women didn't actually have his penis
inside they weren't penetrated yeah but
it's but it's it's ridiculous he has
penetrated them though like he's done it
with his fingers but also because it's
consensual but essentially it's
consensual but it's under a lie false
pretense exactly so the fact that they
weren't able to go look this guy needs
to be imprisoned like I couldn't believe
that he was getting away with it he was
struck from the record though surely I
guess so but like it was the whole I
mean I kind of lost interest towards Jen
but the point was you were just like and
like every single time they found a new
sibling and they were like so here's the
thing
and and because because they were like
this this one woman who was like the
ring leader was like going to people and
she was like you've come up on our radar
as like uh relative because they've had
this website where they people only
friend me sort of [__] yeah and and and
she's like did your parents struggle
with conceiving and one of the people
was like nah nah she was like just go
and ask you
and she's like Mom did uh did you
struggle conceive and she's like no well
your father did and then she's like and
did you go to a doctor hell and she was
like yeah and she's like was the
doctor's name yeah she's like okay then
and like that singing feeling of like
you immediately know that's not your dad
and this happened
constantly this man was populating
and and it turned out he was some white
supremacist who he wanted to um like
breed the the white line basically that
was his thing
he was big religious uh Guy funny all
thing yeah good old religion you know
the thing with that is you know the
whole Aryan thing
weird in it that's what I find strange
because you know the people who tend to
be the most clinging onto the arianism
ugly [__] well yeah and
um
that guy who recently shot up that
Supermarket yeah that was sad
I didn't watch uh my mate sent me a link
and I was like [__] me I I I I watched
the start of it and when he starts
shooting at people I immediately
switched off because I was like this is
too much for me like seeing like an
error and it annoys me uh in on a a deep
like level because you're saying
innocent women just going about their
[__] day and he's and I kind of I
think computer games and movies have
skewed what the reality of shooting
someone is because you say it from a
computer game visual because he's got
his camera on his helmet and um
how do they even get that but he was
live streaming the whole thing and he
just literally shoots a woman and you
just see her immediately dropped at the
floor it's not glamorous it's not you
know it's nothing like what you see on
movies games nothing they're dead
immediately it's brutal and it is like
it's so fast and it it just hit me like
[__] me I just switched off immediately
but apparently he like goes past the
white guy and like apologizes to him or
something like that and I was like these
morons are so [__] up it's repulsive
you know and I just replied to my mate
in the group I was like this is the most
cowardly [__] I've ever seen in my
[__] life and like you just you just
think like you're literally slaughtering
people like that with no
um
no chance of their survival no and no
fairness in that fight is at all you're
using a lethal weapon against women like
it's a very efficiently for Weber I mean
it's it's a semi it was just
automatically it's automatic you know
either automatic or semi-automatic very
efficient way of releasing the lights
from a gun yeah even like yeah there's
just no chance to stop you and it was
just immediately it was so uh
frustrating for me I'm like you [__]
you [__] little [__] you feel tough
do you and um obviously it's happening
in America constantly so we might as
well touch on it because it just
happened to that uh school as well that
was even worse uh not even worse but it
was no like it it was kids you know it's
it's more emotionally it's like you know
on some level you just hope at least
those people in the supermarket had some
level of life before they were taken but
them kids clearly not and it's [__] up
me and the fact that America
uh just keep allowing this over and over
and without changing doing anything
substantially and just keep going
thoughts and prayers and you're like you
know what your country like all all
countries are [__] stupid on some
level but [__] me how many times you
have to learn a lesson Jesus Christ and
how like they don't that's the point is
a lot of people don't see that as a
lesson they see that as a
a necessary evil to allow them to keep
whatever it is that they want and that's
part of it but this is the problem
though the horse is bolted now I don't
know how you get that horse back in do
you know what I mean like that the
problem is their solution is well let's
try and get gun control and people go oh
well you're not gonna be able to control
my guns yeah and selling arms is a huge
thing for America as well it's part of
their bread and butter
um and so unfortunately they've sort of
boxed themselves into this crazy
situation and that's the point is like
you know
it's hard to get a gun in the UK and if
you do you know you have to keep it in
one place which I think is outside the
house the the key for that has to be
kept somewhere else the ammunition has
to be kept somewhere else to the point
where it's almost just inefficient to
have a gun and that's the point is
um in order to show like
if you did use it you meant it yeah you
had to have gone and unlocked a gun
unlocked ammunition loaded that
ammunition into the gun you can never
leave the ammo in a gun those kind of
things there are so many instances in
America of mothers or I've only really
heard their mother's things of their
kids reaching into their like their
handbag pulling out a gun and there was
a mum that was shot in the leg there was
a mum I think uh there was a kid in the
back of the car and the mama just left
the gun in the suit now as you do and
the kid got it obviously and kids go Oh
it's just a gun a bit of fun shot them
I'm in the back with this gun [__] Moon
all you got to think is I guess
differently to the way these people are
going into like schools sometimes it is
natural selection
foreign
if you do leave it leave a a gun lying
around and someone uses it on you
is it an accident is that an accident
yeah it's
um by the way if you get shot by your
own kid maybe it start to maybe you need
to start questioning whether you're
going yeah maybe there should be good
exactly yeah like don't just leave it
lying around your kids exactly no if
there's one if you know like
you know in the UK for example knives we
we have like a knife rock where they're
like high up and we make sure that
they're you know like a gun being far
more dangerous than a knife yeah
probably would what do you do with the
guns well put knives up high just put
the guns low on the floor leave them
just hanging around where's the remote
oh it's just next to the gun yeah
exactly yeah the funny thing is it is a
much more normal thing in the states
like I still feel like guns are quite
shocking in England you know when you
see the people around 10 Downing Street
and stuff with the guns people sort of
go [__] it like you look at it and
you're like wow that is some serious
weapon you got there whereas in America
it's just more like yeah I just got my
gun you're like yeah it's so normal yeah
and I guess to some people like if
you're living out in the middle of
nowhere you want to be a hunter you know
if you want to go out and live out in
the middle of [__] do you know what
they're complaining about
in America literally just background
checks they're not even saying take all
the guns they're going probably want to
double check whether this person's
mentally same before we give them a
killing machine right this is a killing
machine designed for one thing that's
what's made for one thing only right so
the the clue is what it's designed for
and why we shouldn't give them the nuts
people but that's kind of the point is
these people then go nuts be we
shouldn't be giving them to nuts people
because people want the the point is you
can't
um
you can't differentiate between the
people who want to hunt with them and
the people who want to use them at
shooting no but the point is you can do
background checks and if someone has a
proof of an unstable background whether
that be a criminal record for dodgy [__]
or a psychiatric uh issue you don't give
them a gun one of these it's not
complicated one of these kids about 18.
at a very basic level though that's like
I'm not what I'm not saying is take all
the guns away because I do accept the
horses bolted but that is a minimal ask
for the American people to feel a bit
safer my favorite thing is also and even
then it'll take decades for it to take
effect right yeah but it takes very long
time exactly so the longer they leave it
the worse it's going to be and not only
that I think what I found very weird was
there are a lot of people who are like
we need the guns to be able to protect
against the government and I'm like the
government have found really efficient
ways of controlling the population that
don't involve guns like I don't know if
you noticed the last lockdown and stuff
that happened like they don't need guns
they don't need an army
really that is so delusional like we are
so easily controlled like I still can't
believe what what has happened in the
last couple of years sure it blows my
mind that people just handed over the
freedom and was like tiny mind yep no
problem yeah uh we'll all unfurlough
brilliant peers out I'm not doing
anything two years later oh that cost of
living crisis oh where's that come from
it's called cost of lockdown they've
just renamed it one thing I will say
while we're just talking about lockdown
and those kind of things is I think you
know when a junior colleague leaves a
job gather 30 people get all those
people together make sure there's a
party make sure there's alcohol involved
because that's much more important for
me than a funeral absolutely dead people
are gone you know what is the point
exactly well they can't be there exactly
why celebrate them exactly yeah you
should have told them while they're
alive if you love them so much it we
don't need a funeral for you to go and
take out your complicated guilt on
someone else honestly and also with
dying people as well why why be around
the bedside exactly they're not they're
not
exactly if anything you might catch
something so you know it's inefficient
for you as well you need to have two
weeks off work you need to isolate for
all that time I can't be awesome exactly
there's no point but of a drug a bit of
a boost but Nana's on our way out of
course yeah I'll text her this is the
thing she she's got a bit of a dementia
anyway she'll not remember even if I do
come yeah and then when she does
remember she's dead yeah exactly whereas
where is the conservative party having
parties they'll all remember that
absolutely forever the rest of their
lives well they've got the photographs
exactly brilliant yeah thank God someone
that party took photos yeah um I guess
we'll leave it on that leave it on that
one
um thanks for uh for listening to the
Pod uh we will be doing a lot more
because the football season is coming to
a close and we've been working hard but
we are excited to interview some really
cool people again and this was just a
little warm-up for the main events
coming back with all those great guests
you will see on the true Geordie podcast
and this is just a little hangout with
me in laws uh appreciate it bro
appreciate you and hearing me
and justice for Johnny
we'll see you later cheers